and today I am reflecting on my work as
a film composer
[Music]
well it was so beautiful to see this
this come together because when I
started working on on Joker I um I got
the script and I wrote a lot of music
just based on my feelings of the of the
script and and the you know the the
tonality and the sense of musicality
that I was feeling internally
interestingly what I was writing this
music I had this sense of I had the
sense of movement like like
um you know obviously you know that was
you know the cello was my instruments so
there's there's a lot of like hand
gestures that I was in there was a lot
of this kind of upper body
uh Sensations that I was that I was
feeling in the um in the music but I had
never said anything about that too
taught and and there was nothing in the
script that indicated any sort of
dancing or any sort of movement and in
this scene in particular it was you know
it was it was really just like not much
was happening in the in the script and
the scene you know it's it's gonna he
runs into this bathroom and throws away
his gun and looks in the mirror and says
oh there's something like this you know
that was the scope of the scene in The
Script like it was it was really not
very not a big block point or a big
moment and somehow as they were starting
to to shoot the scene and walking
somehow wasn't he just wasn't really
feeling it or something you know he was
having a bit of a hard time just getting
into it and and um and they had already
been you know listening to this music
that I that I composed through the film
on Saturn and uh Todd puts on this um
because on this track and and he says
well maybe you just uh you know just
listen to the music and and see how it
inspires you and then the scene just
appears you know in connection to the
music and he starts he starts this this
dance and this movements which were so
similar to what I was
experiencing when I was recording the
music so one uh you know and it was just
so beautiful to see how it all unfolded
and and it kind of just I guess this
impromptu
situation you know and then the
cinematographer you know starts
following the the movements and it
becomes this kind of like beautiful
fluid uh scene and then we thought sent
it over to me I just I just couldn't
believe that this was the you know
what's what I've ever seen because it
was so similar to what I had kind of
experienced myself so I I feel like it
was just such a beautiful moment of you
know all of that elements of filmmaking
coming together the director he just was
so open to us bringing what we had to
the to the table and he was so willing
to to let us kind of you know do our
thing and then and then he just like
left this unfold and and uh
you know it's it's it's a I think it's a
really um
it was a beautiful a beautiful moment I
think
[Music]
when working on Chernobyl because it's a
it's a real story based on real events
that that so many people that are still
alive experienced and and
for me that was a very different process
than working on a fictional story where
you know anything anything goes really
and and I think there's a level of
respect that you have to have for for
the story and and the survivors and and
you know people that were affected and
people that lost their lives and and so
on so so
so I really wanted to be as true as I as
I could to the story itself like I I
really I really didn't want to
sensationalize anything like I didn't
want to storm in there with uh you know
big big drums in a string orchestra and
kind of you know over dramatize these
events because they're more effective
you know enough as as they are so I went
to this power plant in Lithuania which
is the the sister power plant to
Chernobyl so it's exactly the same as
Chernobyl was and recorded a lot of
sounds that that turned out to be
uh the the main source of of the the
score basically so there's no
instruments in the score it's all the
sounds in the score come from from this
power plant uh with the exception of my
voice which was like the the human
element because I really and you know it
was it was a lot of hassle to to work in
in this way and you know it took a
really long time to to be able to work
with these sounds in in this way that
worked uh musically but I thought it was
just so important to try to try to
understand and to try to capture what
radio activity sounds like because that
was I think that you know the main
character in the in the series that we
couldn't see with our eyes you know you
can't film radioactivity and you can't
explain it really with with words so I
wanted to create a sense of feeling the
radioactivity through the music and in
order to do that you know I I felt like
I had to have actual radio active sounds
so to say and the bridge of death in
particular it's it's just such such an
heartbreaking scene you know you have
all these people on this on this bridge
and they're they're showing off what
they're seeing and for them they're
seeing this incredibly
beautiful
you know situation of unfold before
their eyes but we know that it's going
to be the death of all of them to to
stand on this on this bridge and you
know that most all of them will entire
get very illness as a as a consequence
so it was just you know trying to find
the balance between being uh you know
allowing the emotionality to to be there
but still keeping a sense of of uh
horror you know about you know what what
actually will happen you know that that
was uh yeah that was kind of what I was
trying to achieve you know to to be
emotional but not
too prescriptive you know
how's the writing going
[Music]
so well
hearing something
schopenhauer measure a man's
intelligence against his sensitivity to
noise
do you ever find yourself overwhelmed by
emotion
[Music]
he has to do something
well Tara was so interesting on so many
levels I think Tara just is like layer
upon layer upon layer upon layer of of
you know things that you can dive into
but but I think for for me personally
you know I was writing music as a person
in a film who is posing as another
person
you know but trying to write as herself
you know through through her music so it
was it was so many layers of emotional
complexity because also you know we are
in this in this film we have a character
who has created this completely made up
person who's who's leading a car and
who's like you know the master of the
podium you know when she is conducting
conducting these big orchestras but but
somehow that's also just on a line you
know and and she
in her heart of hearts wants to be
writing
music that's much more experimental and
fragile in its nature much more seeking
so she has this insecurities about
herself that comes through
in the music that she's that she's
writing you know that's completely
disconnected to her her Podium person
you know so it was just it was so just
so interesting you know to write through
went with and into all of these stairs
it was it was really really wonderful
and um and also really exciting to to
see
you know to feel the the actual real
life response to the film you know
because it really you know For Better or
For Worse uh you know however you want
to look at it really shook the the world
you know with with that take on how we
are allowed to write stories about women
or represent women as as you know what
is the spectrum of how we can
how we can talk about women's characters
and their actions and and their their uh
positions of power or or not or
non-power you know and and of course
first and foremost the position of of
female conductors you know I read so
many articles about female conductors
uh you know in the real world after
after this film came out that was such a
um such a joy for me to to you know
whether or not you agree with the
approach that we we decided to take for
for the film you know because obviously
a lot of people but they were not in
agreement and and uh which I which I
completely respect and and understand of
course but I think the real victory in
in whichever camp that you
is that that um female conductors got a
lot of space in in in you know the
mainstream media and and I think that
was just just fantastic you know I think
it was really it really put a lot of
focus into the women because we have so
many brilliant women conductors and and
I worked with a field of a few of them
who were just so
unbelievably brilliant uh at their job
and so such amazing musicians you know
and it was so fantastic to see just like
that um the focused uh finally I'm going
towards them I've seen a million
so-called psychics each one is fake
I do not believe in psychics come with
Meats spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
voice
and wants to be heard
we are here listening
a hurricane in Venice is probably the
most classical score that I've done to
date and in my work I will often be
exploring you know building instruments
or phone sounds or implementing you know
these kind of
experimentation into the into the music
but in this in this core I was really
excited to to just focus purely on the
music and focus purely on the
instruments and I think that was also
largely because I was so interested in
the music history of of this period And
I think it's it's such an interesting
time in music history where composers
and the World At Large really you know
that there's they've seen their world
completely you know been bombed apart in
in during the second world war and and
they they start asking all of these
questions like you know why are we doing
this what is music what a sound what is
the these all these preconceived ideas
about the world and about the music that
are that I've had and who am I and you
know where am I going towards like how
am I going to rebuild my my world and um
and I think composers especially the
kind of forward thinking um you know
experimental
classical composers if you will um we're
we're really abandoning Melody and
abandoning this this old musical
structures like the Sonata performance
is is completely thrown out the window
and all these all these old structures
and you know they're they're we're
seeking to rebuild themselves and
reinvent themselves by by exploring you
know extend the techniques of playing
and and uh different forms of musicality
like you know we have the the eight
tonal very mathematical sense of
everything is very structured and and
you know where to emotions fit within
that you know either that very uh
mathematical approach or a chance
compositions become become a thing and
all these all these different different
ways of of uh of Expressions that the
the composers are looking towards and we
we're in the film we're really seeing
exactly those transitions as well like
we're seeing poro essentially asking the
same questions you know so we're much
closer to him and his emotional Journey
than we are in a lot of the other films
you know we get to go deeper into his
into his uh emotional tap so he's
exploring you know who he was before the
war what happened to him during the War
and who he will
we will be how you will be uh you know
reinvent themselves and himself and he
so he retires and he and he's trying to
to you know just focus on gardening and
you know start to completely different
different uh career
so and I thought there were just so many
parallels between what we're seeing in
music history and what we're seeing him
him go through so so basically how I
approached it was the kind of
superimpose the use of Melody into these
moments of time that we see in the film
you know so we have in the beginning you
know he he wakes up from this this dream
state and and and as a lot of times in
the film we're unaware of you know
whether this is real or it's not real if
there's a dream if it's a ghost like
where where where we're sitting so so
the way that the melody is is working in
that in those very first uh moments is
almost like in this part those days
between non-melody and Melody between
not going somewhere and going somewhere
in between the waking and the sleeping
between the natural and the and the
supernatural so that's almost like this
this in between instead and um
and then we have the moments where we're
looking at the at the past uh for
example and in connection to the the
girl who's one of the first victims uh
you know we're looking at her and in the
past and then we are we're approached
with this this you know this romantic
you know more romantic Melodies and and
we're taking on a more um uh melancholic
uh backwards looking Outlook and and
then for example towards that when the
world starts breaking apart we have much
more like a tonal music and structural
music and everything in unison and
working very fracturably as as things as
things start to uh to to crumple and
then and in the end where that where we
have the big
revealing that and and the world kind of
restructures itself to to move forward
when we're leaning towards the more
eternal uh uh
tonality that that these composers are
moving towards moving uh moving forward
you know so so it's there's this big
connection between between the history
of the music of this of this time and
the story in my mind